-Welcome back to the show,
everybody!
I'm here with Questlove.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we are about to play
Pictionary.
But we've made it
much, much tougher.
This is "Impossible Pictionary,"
and we're gonna need some help.
He is the star --
Is that what you need
after a long day of traveling?
-Mm-hmm.
-"Impossible Pictionary."
-Word challenges.
-Yes. He is the star
of the new romantic comedy
"Your Place or Mine," streaming
on Netflix this Friday.
Give it up for my partner,
Ashton Kutcher!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
My man.
We got this.
-It's goodness.
-We got this, buddy.
You know Quest.
-How are you?
-I'm good.
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right!
You know him, you love him.
Now, let's meet
Questlove's partner.
Her new film,
"Somebody I Used to Know,"
will launch globally
on Prime Video this Friday.
Give it up for Alison Brie!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Whoa!
-Hi.
-How you doing?
-Good, good.
-Oh, this is a good one.
-Oh!
-No "psych"!
No "psych"!
-She is so fun.
[ Laughter ]
Here's how the game works.
It's just like regular
"Pictionary,"
except the clues
are much harder to get.
To give everyone
a fighting chance,
all of the clues will be
Valentine's Day-themed.
-I got it, I got it.
-You already know it?
-I already got it.
-We got this, we got this.
We got this one.
-Cupid! Cupid! Cupid! Cupid!
-All right, not Cupid.
-Hallmark! Hallmark!
[ Laughter ]
-Aston --
-Have we started?
Are we started?
-No, but let's do it.
Ashton, you draw first.
You guys can have a seat
right over there.
Alison, you go there.
-My clothes are coming off.
I'm already getting undressed
for the game.
-Wow, no.
That's not the way it is.
-Whoa!
-For every point I get right,
I'm gonna get undressed
just a little more.
[ Laughter ]
-No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is not happening.
-Wait. Hold on. Am I --
Do I go -- I go one?
-No, you don't have
to go in order.
-I can go anywhere.
-Any number.
-Okay, got it.
-We got this, buddy.
Cupid!
[ Audience shouting ]
-Wait. Hold on.
I feel like I'm on
"The Price is Right"!
-I don't know
what they're saying.
Good, good, good.
I'm not looking.
Ashton, you can draw now.
-[ Laughing ]
Okay.
Okay. Okay.
-Oh, God.
-Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, ready?
-Yep.
-Here we go.
-Cupid!
[ Laughter ]
Hallmark!
Mailbox?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, tunnel of love!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at the tunnel.
-That's unbelievable!
-Wow!
Tunnel of love!
-Yeah!
Valentines!
Love tunnel!
-Well done, well done.
Quest, good luck to you, bud.
-No!
-You know what?
In my years of being here,
no one ever picks 10.
-Yeah.
-Ooh.
-I'm gonna pick 10.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel good about it.
-I don't think words are written
on number 10.
-Now I know why no one ever...
[ Laughter ]
I could do this.
-Okay.
-All right,
mind meld, mind meld.
-I got you.
I hope I got you.
[ Laughter ]
I haven't been to sleep
in hours, though.
-Sure, sure.
-You ready?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-I don't have to be ready.
Do you want to come here,
Alison?
-Yeah. Yes.
Guys, guys.
Okay, okay.
Cupid!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Cupid.
-Baby fish mouth.
Baby fish mouth!
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Bee.
Be yourself.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bee...
Bumblebee.
Bee.
-Valentines.
-Be mine!
Be mine!
-Yes!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo!
-Oh, wow.
-Wow.
Wow.
-Wow. Not bad.
-That was -- That was --
-That was one of the worst bees
I've ever seen.
-She's a genius.
-In the history of --
-Well done, well done.
-That's how you draw a tunnel.
I mean, come on.
[ Laughter ]
That is a bee?
Come on.
All right, here we go.
What number, guys?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Everyone said four.
[ Laughter ]
-Why'd you look over there?
-I'm like, "Dude,
Valentine's Day themed?"
-Okay. Okay.
Okay. "Romancing the Stone"!
Blank page!
-Ready for this?
-Blank. Shooting blanks!
-We got this.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't start!
I didn't start yet.
-Oh, sorry, sorry.
Okay, go.
-Here we go.
Ready?
-Okay, okay, okay.
Oval.
You got an oval.
You got a bowl. Bowl.
Bowl of honey.
Bowl of honey love.
Bowl -- Bowl.
Walking bowl.
You got a bowl with legs.
You got a bow-legged --
Bow-legged!
Bow-legged bee!
A bathtub!
We've got a tub full --
Bubble bath!
-Yes!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow!
-Yeah-ya.
Yeah-ya.
♪♪
-No, no.
All right.
We got to silence this.
-Bubble bath!
-Yes!
-We're crushing!
-Jimmy, I'm having
a wardrobe malfunction!
Can you zip this up for me?
[ Laughter ]
-Hey!
-Zip it up, zip it up.
There you go, okay, thank you.
-Fair enough.
All right. All right.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Breathes deeply ]
-Great.
[ Laughter ]
I'm psyched.
Whoa!
-Take this off.
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy, go fix it!
-Come on.
-All right. All right.
You ready?
-I think I am.
Are you ready?
-Who's coming with me?
-Okay. I got you.
-All right.
Okay, so...
[ Laughter ]
Got a thing here like this.
-You had me at hello?
-Okay.
And then, there's this little...
-Wooden horse bed?
-Okay, and then there's --
-Bed of roses.
-Okay.
Okay.
And just stay with me.
Stay with me.
-Bunk bed, bunk bed.
-Okay, okay.
-On top.
Love on top.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Okay.
-Looks like a balance beam.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Caligula, Caligula.
-Okay, see --
-Caligula...
-Ménage à trois?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-Ohh!
-Ménage à trois?!
-Oh, couples massage!
-Couples massage!
[ Ding ]
♪ We got it, we got it ♪
[ Sad tuba ]
-I heard the "bur" sound!
-No, no, no.
-What?
-That was genius.
-That was a "burrrr."
That was a "burrr."
-I want to frame that.
I want to frame that.
-Yeah, you have to frame that.
Couple's massage.
-Caligula?
-"Caligula," is what he said.
-What's Valentiney
about Caligula?
[ Laughter ]
-Ménage à trois?
-In the Thompson household,
that was a classic.
-Quest, you and Ashton,
for the final round.
-Yes, okay.
-Okay?
And here's the deal --
whoever gets this first,
whatever team gets it first,
wins the whole thing.
-Wait. It's a co-flow?
-It's a co-flow.
-We do it together, okay.
-Everybody's standing,
and I also want to be standing.
-It's a ménage à draw.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yes.
-What number are we doing?
-I don't know.
-Six!
-Someone said six.
-We got to do the same one?
-Want to stand?
-Doing the same one.
-Standing games.
-Ménage à draw.
Oh, gee.
-Wait. Who's that?
-What is that?
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, if we don't know.
-You've got to do it.
You gotta do
what you think it is.
-Okay.
Okay. Okay.
-I don't know what it is!
-Draw what you think it is.
-Okay.
Okay.
-You want me to clear your page?
-Okay, okay.
Wait. Hold on.
He's gotta clear his page.
-Okay.
-Shooting blanks!
Shooting blanks!
-Draw what you think this is.
-Staying standing.
I'm staying standing.
-Okay, ready?
-You ready?
-Cupid. Hallmark.
-Couples massage.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Cube, rectangle.
-Table.
Uh, box.
-What in the -- what?
-Cornhole.
-A stove!
Hot!
-Stove, stove.
-Hot, hot!
-My stove's on fire!
-Hot!
Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
One in the oven!
-Bun in the oven!
-Yes.
You're saying what I'm saying
but better.
-You're saying what I'm saying.
-Hot stove.
Standing on the stove.
-Hot, hot.
Burning hot love.
Stove...
-People on --
-Burner.
-Smoke.
[ Buzzer ]
-This was impossible.
-Wait, wait, wait.
-Holding hands.
-What do they look like
they're doing?
-They look like they're
wrestling.
-Dancing.
-Wrestling with...
Wrestling -- wrestle fire.
Wrestling match.
Stovetop stuffing.
-Stove wrestle.
-Russell...stover.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-Wrestle stover.
Wre--
[ Rim shot ]
-I say we do one more.
-Now, I'm looking over there.
-I think we have to get judges.
-Now, I'm looking over there
with you looking over there
'cause we're looking over there!
-Judges,
give them the points, right?
[ Dinging ]
Yeah! We got it!
We got Russell Stover.
We had to get Russell Stover.
That's pretty good.
-All right.
My thanks to Ashton Kutcher,
the champ.
Alison brie, Questlove.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're talking to Ashton
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Russell Stover!